obviously you hear that there's gonna be
more films in the Wizarding World
yeah we just found out I would be like
duh I'm gonna be a part of it but what
was it about this one in particular that
you were like yes I want to do this i
met david yates in this club in london
and it was a christmas and he was by
fire and he just started telling me this
story and i knew that he had worked on
the potter films but i didn't know yeah
and it was so toxic ating the way he
talked about the story and that happened
about over five months every time they
wouldn't even show you the script Joe
was still writing the script he would
like to tell it to me with this kind of
light was actually like sitting by fire
and they told and I just thought
everything about it so intoxicating and
the period I don't know I've always
loved that Gatsby twenties waring 20
every character has such a physicality a
quirk about them what did you guys
really want to bring into your
characters I was always trying to figure
out the little bit of internal joy she
may have that she might not show other
people too much it was really just kind
of to have a secret in her choice
because the exteriors of it tougher your
two characters are brand new how
exciting was that for you guys to get to
develop these characters there weren't
any novels that it was just based on an
encyclopedia of creatures so it was
great they look to us to fill in the
gaps and there wasn't a large
expectation to be like you know yeah
this the novel and we were able to bring
lots of table and it made for a really
freeing play playground dad yeah it was
really fun that there they are wonderful
people to jump Queenie is is a delight
to inhabit she's she's warm she's she's
funny she's freaking adorable she the
person you were most excited to tell
yeah I texted her and she was she was so
excited she was so excited yeah yeah was
she like are you gonna have a wand first
question good guy bad guy five one-liner
and mines are you gonna have one I don't
think I've seen anyone wield a wand as
aggressive Whitney you're not the first
person to say I brought to God no I
can't remember I feel like there was a
lot of like it was a lot of that oh yeah
yeah there was whipping yeah yeah there
was there was okay well first of all you
need some real wood because essentially
water flows through wood so energy water
okay so that's that's your inner inner I
like it I feel like I'm not laughing
with it like the giggle water right mr.
English guy I think your egg is hatching
I wanna be lizard